Over the years I've been making videos,
lots of people have suggested
that I should see
the Hallig islands in Germany.
Mostly because of the tiny trains.
Every few years,
some media outlet does a story about
how the people who live out on the islands
have their own personal trains
to get them to and from the mainland.
And yes, I'm going to talk about those,
but the story here is way
more interesting than that.
Although yes, the best way to get to some
of the Hallig islands from the mainland
is on board tiny trains.
And the railway staff
here are going to let me take a ride.
IN GERMAN:
But there's a bigger question:
why is there a tiny railroad here?
Who builds a railroad
instead of just... a road?
If you're building
sea defenses in the 1930s
and you need to get a load of
heavy material across a tidal flat,
well, rail is your most efficient option.
And to understand why they
need those defenses,
we need to take a look
at the bigger picture.
But unfortunately
I'm not allowed to fly a drone here
because this is a wildlife reserve.
If you look at aerial images,
you can see that the whole of this area,
the North German coast, is protected
by these barrier islands.
This area is the Wadden Sea, hundreds
of kilometers of sandbars and mudflats
that act as a natural wave break
and storm defense.
That's what they were boosting with
the earthworks here.
Manage these islands correctly,
you'll protect all the cities
on the mainland from flooding.
Plus, people have lived
on these islands for centuries now.
They'll happily take the storm
defense for themselves.
And the free railroad that comes with it.
One of the problems with living on
what's basically a bit of sea defense
is that you're going to be
the one that gets flooded.
These islands go mostly underwater
50 or 60 times a year, usually in winter.
The local term for it
translates as "land under".
The houses are up on mounds
to protect them, and they're built high
enough for now. But one of the reasons
that the railway is still in regular use
is that it's still helping
to build the sea defenses.
It seems strange
to describe an island as something
that needs to be kept healthy,
but yeah, that's why the railway's here.
Yes, the locals have their own trains.
Very rarely, if they're staying on
the island, tourists can ride too.
And it looks quirky and interesting.
But the reason behind it
is to stop these islands,
and eventually the mainland,
being flooded by rising seas.